Gráfica todos los posibles valores para "h"
en la recta numérica,
que cumplan la siguiente desigualdad,
y esta siguiente desigualdad
tiene una cierta peculiaridad,
que tiene valor absoluto,
tenemos el valor absoluto de "h"
-19 /2
esto tiene que ser menor que -12.
¿Y cómo resolvemos
este tipo de desigualdades?
Pues lo primero que hay que hacer,
o lo mejor que se me ocurre,
es despejar lo más que se pueda el valor absoluto de "h", lo que tiene que ver con el valor absoluto,
en este caso de "h"
de un lado de esta desigualdad,
y de hecho,
creo que sería mucho más fácil
dejarlo del lado izquierdo,
y por lo tanto lo que voy a hacer primero,
es sumar 19 enteros 1/2
de ambos lados de esta desigualdad,
de aquí
y del lado derecho de la desigualdad,
también voy a sumar 19 enteros 1/2
¡y ojo!
Fíjate como la desigualdad se conserva
y entonces estos dos se van
y me queda simple y sencillamente
del lado izquierdo de esta desigualdad,
el valor absoluto de "h",
mientras que del lado derecho me queda -12
más 19 enteros 1/2,
esto es 7 enteros 1/2
-12 más 19 enteros 1/2, es lo mismo
que 7 enteros 1/2 del lado derecho de esta desigualdad,
y por lo tanto tengo que el valor absoluto de "h"
es menor que 7 enteros 1/2
lo padre del asunto
es que ya tenemos despejado el valor absoluto de "h"
de un lado de esta desigualdad,
sin embargo, ahora
¿cómo podemos resolver esta desigualdad?
Y quiero que recuerdes que el valor absoluto
también representa una cierta distancia.
¿A qué distancia estamos o
qué tan lejos estamos del 0?
Es decir, aquí estamos diciendo que me quiero tomar
todas las "h" que cumplan,
que su valor absoluto
sea menor que 7 enteros 1/2,
ó dicho de otra manera,
que la distancia de cualquier "h",
de estas "h" que van a ser una solución al 0
sea menor que 7 enteros 1/2,
y bueno, de una manera rápida
lo que primero que nos podemos dar cuenta,
es que cualquier número que sea menor
que 7 enteros 1/2,
y que además sea positivo,
pues cumple esto,
por ejemplo si yo me tomo el 3,
la distancia del 3 al 0
es menor que 7 enteros 1/2,
por lo tanto podemos decir que "h"
tiene que ser menor que 7 enteros 1/2
pero,
hay que tener cuidado, no son todos las "h"
que sean menores que 7 enteros 1/2,
es decir que tenemos
que parar en un cierto punto,
¿y en qué punto tenemos que parar?
Pues bueno "h" a su vez tiene que ser mayor
que -7 enteros 1/2,
date cuenta que cualquier número que esté
entre -7 enteros 1/2 y el 0,
cuando yo me tomo su valor absoluto es
mucho más chico que 7 enteros 1/2,
por lo tanto ya tengo que -7 enteros 1/2,
tiene que ser menor que
"h" y a su vez, tiene que ser menor
que 7 enteros 1/2,
así que ahora sí podemos ponerlo
en nuestra recta numérica.
Si por aquí tengo al 7 y por aquí tengo al 8
y de este lado por aquí tengo al -7
y por acá tengo al -8
entonces todas las "h"
que son mi solución
y que cumplen esta desigualdad con valor absoluto,
son aquellas
que son más grandes que 7 enteros 1/2
y a su vez son más pequeñas
que 7 enteros 1/2,
y date cuenta que es un intervalo abierto,
porque nuestra desigualdad es estricta
y por aquí tenemos al menos 7 enteros 1/2
y yo quiero todas las "h"
que estén entre estos dos puntos,
va a cumplir mi desigualdad con valor absoluto,
así que déjame dibujarlos en ésta recta numérica.
Cualquier cantidad
que esté en este intervalo,
claramente su distancia al 0
es menor que 7 enteros 1/2.